The other one, the other comment though, that I just find hilarious is that it was the criticism that our podcast lacks structure. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 83, recorded on June 13th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about Bryce's Array 2022 keynote talk, empty spaces, and more. Now we're Googling Blue Yeti signs. All right, we're just going to do it. So stereo, omnidirectional, bidirectional. You see, I told you. I told you. Boom.
另外一个，关于另外一条评论，我觉得太搞笑了，那是批评我们的播客缺乏结构。欢迎来到ADSP，第83期播客，录制于2022年6月13日。我是康纳，今天和我一起主持的是布莱斯，我们讨论了布莱斯的2022年Array主题演讲、空空间等等。现在我们在用谷歌搜索Blue Yeti的标志。好了，我们这就开始。所以立体声、全向、双向。你看，我告诉过你。我告诉过你。砰。
Do you have it? Boom. I told you it was that one. Okay. Now I'm going to say something. And now I'm going to say something. Looks good. Looks good.
你拿到了吗？砰。我告诉过你是那个。好了。现在我要说点什么。现在我要说点什么。看起来不错。看起来不错。
All right. High five. Woo! That was the sound of... This is so weird. Have we seen each other since we started this podcast? We have not. No.
好了。击掌。呜！那是……的声音。这太奇怪了。自从我们开始做这个播客以来，我们见过面吗？我们没有。没有。
No. I actually think the last time we were... Face to face. Wait, was the last time we met each other was when we were on our 2019 trip? No, no, no no no no Prague 2020 oh yeah that's true and we were you working at NVIDIA at the time?
没有。其实我觉得我们最后一次……面对面。等等，我们最后一次见面是不是在2019年的那次旅行中？不，不，不，不，不，布拉格2020年，哦对，确实如此，当时你在英伟达工作吗？
no definitely because I started that trip was right after I started at NVIDIA and we started this podcast in November of 2019, correct? Did we? We started it pre-pandemic? 2020, no.
不，绝对是的，因为我开始那次旅行正是在我加入英伟达之后，我们是在2019年11月开始做这个播客的，对吧？是吗？我们在大流行之前开始的？2020年，不是。
No, we started it post-pandemic. Listener, do you remember when this podcast started? Oh, yeah. The reason I'm thinking it was 2019 is because in a talk that I gave, I showed a photo of Dublin being like, oh, yeah, Bryce were here. But it was actually – it was a year later that I was – and I think it was meeting C++ and it was an online presentation. And I said almost one year ago was when this photo was taken of Bryce and I who – big announcement. We're starting a podcast. We're starting a podcast. So that was taken of Bryce and I who big announcement we're starting a podcast so that was November of 2020 and that was definitely uh post pandemic yeah so yeah this is the first time
不，我们是在大流行之后开始的。听众朋友们，你们还记得这个播客是什么时候开始的吗？哦，是的。我以为是2019年的原因是，在我做的一次演讲中，我展示了一张都柏林的相片，当时我想，哦，对了，布莱斯当时也在那儿。但实际上——那是一年之后，我想那是Meeting C++会议，那是一个在线演讲。我说过，这张照片是大约一年前我和布莱斯拍的——重大宣布。我们要开始做一个播客了。我们要开始做一个播客了。所以那是2020年11月我和布莱斯拍的照片，所以那是2020年11月，那绝对是，呃，大流行之后，所以，是的，这是第一次
in over two years then so yeah February of uh 2020 was the last time we saw each other and yeah we're here in San Diego. It's very weird. I have to be honest. It's extremely weird because I'm sitting like two feet away from Bryce. We could also sit much closer and whisper into the microphone. Honestly, I'm very happy we live in separate cities. I mean, not in general.
距离上次见面已经两年多了，所以，呃，2020年2月是我们最后一次见面，然后，是的，我们现在在圣迭戈。这感觉非常奇怪。老实说。极其奇怪，因为我坐得离布莱斯只有两英尺远。我们其实可以坐得更近一点，对着麦克风说悄悄话。说实话，我很高兴我们住在不同的城市。我是说，不是总的来说。
Wow. Wow. Not like it would be nice if we were in the same city but for the sake of this podcast i don't know if i could handle doing this on a regular base just standing there's way too much eye contact i'm just not used to the and that's the thing is I'm usually this close to the mic but here because of my uncomfortability I'm coming in or going out in and out this is great
哇。哇。倒不是说我们在同一个城市会有多好，但为了这个播客着眼，我不知道我是否能应付经常这样面对面，站在这里对视的眼神太多了，我实在不习惯这种……而且问题就在于，我通常离麦克风这么近，但在这里，由于我的不自在，我总是凑近或者退开，进进出出的，这太棒了
this is great production value it's like if we're trying to get serious and you lean in we're both leaning in and then there's literally like six inches between it's we need to do this with multiple mics next time I brought my mic you're the one who didn't bring your mic because dear listener live from pldi 2022 adsp the podcast that doesn't explain why i didn't bring my mic it doesn't but it explains
这制作水准太棒了，就像如果我们试图变得严肃，而你凑过来，我们两个都凑过去，然后之间实际上只有六英寸的距离，我们下次需要用多个麦克风来做这个，我带了我的麦克风，只有你没带麦克风，因为亲爱的听众朋友们，现场直播来自PLDI 2022，ADSP，这个不解释为什么我没带麦克风的播客，它虽然不解释
why we are we i was explaining why we didn't have our microphones with us because we are at the PLDI conference. Correct. Well, I have my microphone with me. Connor doesn't have his microphone with him. I mean, I flew out on Saturday and you flew out yesterday. Yeah. And you pinged me. I'm just doing a pop-in.
为什么我们不……我刚才在解释为什么我们没有带麦克风，因为我们在PLDI会议上。没错。好吧，我带了我的麦克风。康纳没带他的麦克风。我是说，我周六飞过来的，你昨天飞过来的。对。然后你给我发了信息。我只是顺便过来一下。
I'm just popping in keynote, popping out. And Bryce pinged me on Saturday being like, should we record in San Diego? And I was like, well, I'm already here. Also, the room we're recording in is very cold. So we're both like shivering. Yeah. I'm wearing a big, bright, pastel pink hoodie that I picked up in La Jolla yesterday. As Bryce pronounces it, La Jolla.
我只是来做个主题演讲，然后就走。然后布莱斯周六给我发信息问，我们要不要在圣迭戈录制？然后我说，好吧，我已经在这儿了。另外，我们录音的这个房间非常冷。所以我们俩都在发抖。是的。我穿着一件大大的、鲜艳的粉彩粉色连帽衫，这是我昨天在拉霍亚买的。按照布莱斯的读音，叫“La Jolla”。
Because you didn't bring it. You didn't bring a sweater, did you? I mean, we're on the border of Mexico. Do you even own pants? I think you only own shorts. No, I did bring a pair of Lululemon pants. Of course. Which I will be... Please sponsor us. Yeah. Also Bubbly. Yeah, Bubbly, what's up?
因为你没带。你没带毛衣，对吧？我是说，我们都在墨西哥边境了。你甚至有长裤吗？我觉得你只有短裤。不，我确实带了一条Lululemon的裤子。当然。我会……请赞助我们。对，还有Bubbly。对，Bubbly，最近怎么样？
I mean, I think it's much less likely we'll get a Lulu sponsor. So what are we talking about today? Well, Bryce just had his keynote. Are we going to talk about PLDI? Yeah, we should talk about PLDI. Today is the screen just went black. I think it's fine. I think it's fine.
我的意思是，我觉得我们获得Lulu赞助的可能性要小得多。那么我们今天在聊什么呢？好吧，布莱斯刚刚做完了他的主题演讲。我们要聊聊PLDI吗？对，我们应该聊聊PLDI。今天屏幕刚刚变黑了。我觉得没问题。我觉得没问题。
It's just a blank screen screensaver. Yeah. Oh, I don't have screensavers. I've never had a screensaver. Gotcha. I don't believe in screensavers. Okay. You want to expound on that or should we get back to PLD?
它只是一个空白的屏幕保护程序。对。哦，我没有屏幕保护程序。我从来没有用过屏幕保护程序。明白了。我不相信屏幕保护程序。好吧。你想详细阐述一下，还是我们该回到PLDI？
I always have the default desktop background and the default screen saver. It's just, I don't know. It's my thing. All right. Real expression of creativity there, but okay. But here, yes, we just finished attending the array workshop. So the way PLDI, for those that aren't regular listeners or have forgotten or aren't aware, it's the Program Language Design and Implementation Conference.
我总是使用默认的桌面背景和默认的屏幕保护程序。就是，我不知道。这是我的习惯。好吧。那里真是充满了创造力的表达，不过好吧。但在这里，是的，我们刚刚参加完array研讨会。所以PLDI的形式是，对于那些不是常听节目的听众，或者忘记了，或者不知道的人来说，它是编程语言设计与实现会议。
It's actually starting on Wednesday. So Wednesday, Thursday, Friday is PLDI. And then the Monday and Tuesday and a little bit Wednesday as well are co-located workshops. So I think there's a three-day PLMW, which is the Programming Language Mentorship Workshop, and that focuses on technical research, blah, blah, blah. There's a bunch of other workshops, but the workshop that Bryce was keynoting at and I was speaking at was the Array Workshop. How'd that go, Bryce? I think it went great. I finished my slides about five minutes before the talk, so just-in-time slide delivery.
它实际上是从周三开始的。所以周三、周四、周五是PLDI。然后周一、周二以及周三的一部分是同期举办的研讨会。所以我想有一个为期三天的PLMW，也就是编程语言导师研讨会，它专注于技术研究，巴拉巴拉。还有一堆其他的研讨会，但是布莱斯做主题演讲、我也在上面发言的研讨会是Array研讨会。进展如何，布莱斯？我觉得进展很顺利。我在演讲前大约五分钟才完成幻灯片，所以是即时幻灯片交付。
I can confirm that was a missed opportunity to say just-in-time slide something something. I did. I just said that. But you didn't say just-in-time. You said just-in-time slide delivery. Did you say just-in-time? I literally said that. He doesn't listen to me, listener.
我可以证实，那是一个错过说“即时幻灯片什么的”的机会。我说了。我刚刚就这么说的。但你没说“即时”。你说了“即时幻灯片交付”。你说了“即时”吗？我真的说了。听众朋友们，他不听我说话。
I'm just too weirded out. By the way, I'm used to interacting with people through monitors now has picked up some bad anti-social tendencies i mean picked up they were always there i think it's just uh with regular practice you know are you an introvert or an extrovert oh definitely baseline introvert people don't believe me yeah everyone say they don't believe me but that's the thing it's, where do you like, what's your recharge method? Is it I've got spreadsheets and publisher schedule and things that I like to update daily like little graphs you know diet stuff and if I go too long without updating that like it starts to give me anxiety because I know that like seven days from now I'm gonna have to go and like try and backfill everything that I missed and the whole life
我只是太不习惯了。顺便说一句，我现在习惯了通过显示器与人互动，这导致我养成了一些不好的反社交倾向，我是说“养成”，它们其实一直都在，我觉得只是在经过长期的练习之后……你是一个内向的人还是外向的人？哦，绝对是骨子里的内向者。人们都不相信我。对，每个人都说他们不相信我，但关键是，你喜欢怎样恢复精力？是不是我有电子表格和发布日程表，我喜欢每天更新它们，比如小图表，你知道的，饮食之类的事情，如果我太久不更新这些，我就会开始感到焦虑，因为我知道从现在算起七天后，我将不得不去尝试回填我错失的所有内容，然后整个生活
gets out of whack I run my life on spreadsheets and like if I don't if I'm not able to update that but I mean I'm a very extroverted introvert. I used to think that I was an introvert, and then recently some people close to me have pointed out that I am, in fact, the most extroverted person that they know. I'm trying to get my flight back upgraded, and we're waiting here on the live chat from the airline to see whether it can happen and and it's just the suspense is killing me it's killing me well
都会被打乱。我的生活靠电子表格运行，如果我不能更新它——但我其实是一个非常外向的内向者。我过去认为自己是一个内向者，然后最近一些我亲近的人指出，我实际上是我认识的最外向的人。我正在试图把我的回程机票升级，我们正在这里等待航空公司的在线聊天，看看这是否能实现，这种悬念简直快把我折磨死了。快把我折磨死了。好吧
we'll find out how we've been recording for what nine minutes now and there's nine minutes before this break ends yeah a lot of technical difficulties not no shade on z who is a professor at carnegie mellon who's running the morning session of Array. He had nothing to do with it, but they started trying to set up the technical live YouTube stream slash gather stream slash whatever, like two minutes before the hour when Bryce was supposed to start speaking. And it didn't take off until 9.23. And then...
我们会知道我们已经录制了多久，呃，九分钟了，在这次休息结束前还有九分钟。是的，有很多技术故障，绝对不是在针对泽（Z），他是卡耐基梅隆大学的教授，负责Array的早晨场次。这跟他没关系，但他们开始试图建立技术直播YouTube流/gather流/或者别的什么时，距离布莱斯本该开始演讲的时间只有两分钟。直到9点23分才弄好。然后……
Connor knows exactly. And Connor kindly timed my talk. So it took 56 minutes. It's like I never... Like these days, I don't really kindly timed my talk. So it took 56 minutes. It's like, I never, I like these days, I don't really rehearse my talk at a time. I just like sort of like intuitively know like what I'm going to say and like how long it's going to take. But it always surprises me how, like how on target I am for, I was like, this is roughly an hour of content and I clocked in or no, I think I gave him the estimate before the
康纳算得清清楚楚。而且康纳好心地帮我的演讲计时了。所以花了56分钟。就像我从来不……就像这些天，我真的不会提前排练演讲的时间。我只是凭直觉知道我要讲什么以及大概需要多长时间。但总是让我惊讶的是，我是如此地切中要害，我当时想，这大约是一小时的内容，我计时——或者说，不，我想我是在演讲前给他的估计。
talk. I think this is going to be 50 minutes or so. And I clocked in at 56 minutes. Yeah, it's quite impressive. Do we want to talk? I mean, we'll link it. It'll be online by the time this airs in probably a week and a half from today. It's June 13th.
我觉得这大概是50分钟左右。我最终用时56分钟。是的，这相当令人印象深刻。我们要聊聊吗？我的意思是，我们会把链接放出来。等这期节目播出时，大概是一周半之后，它就会上线了。今天是6月13日。
This will probably air, yeah, two Fridays from now. Do we want to talk about empty spaces? Did you just come up with this in the last four days? It was a thing that I invented over the course of the past week or so. So I'll just let you sum up in the next five to ten minutes. Well, the basic premise of my talk, of the back half of my talk, is that iterators are a bad abstraction for multidimensional iteration and that maybe we need
这期节目大概会在，嗯，从今天算起的两个星期五之后播出。我们要聊聊空空间（empty spaces）吗？你是不是在过去四天里刚想出这个的？这是我在过去一周左右的时间里发明的东西。所以我先让你在接下来的五到十分钟内做个总结。好吧，我的演讲的基本前提，也就是我演讲的后半部分，是迭代器对于多维迭代来说是一种糟糕的抽象，也许我们需要
a new abstraction and so the abstraction that I came up with is sort of like an extension of ranges but for multiple dimensions and so I'm calling it spaces and the idea is that you have a
一个新的抽象，所以我提出的抽象有点像是范围（ranges）的扩展，但是适用于多维度，所以我称之为空间（spaces），其理念是你可以对
you can call begin and end on a range but on a space you can call md begin or md end on it. And when you do that, you give it as a template parameter the extent which you're calling it upon. And then that returns you an iterator over that extent. And when you call md begin and md end, you can feed into it a tuple of stuff,
范围调用begin和end，但对于空间，你可以对它调用md begin或md end。当你这样做时，你将你所调用的范围（extent）作为模板参数传递给它。然后它会返回给你一个在该范围上的迭代器。当你调用md end和md begin时，你可以向其中输入一个元组，
sort of arbitrary stuff. And the idea is that that is how the outermost loops pass things to the innermost loops. So like the outermost loop, you know, is just going to be like an iterator over maybe indices, you know, of ints. And so then you take that int, and then you feed it in to the md begin and md end call for the next innermost loop, and that means that that next innermost loop has access to that, to whatever iteration it's in,
某种任意的元组。其理念是，这就是最外层循环向最内层循环传递东西的方式。所以最外层循环，你知道的，就只是一个迭代器，可能关于索引，你知道的，就是int类型的。然后你取那个int，接着把它输入到下一个最内层循环的md begin和md end调用中，这意味着下一个最内层循环可以访问到那个东西，访问到它所在的迭代，
the index of the iteration that it's in in the outermost loop, and so from that you can sort of incrementally build up the final index that your iterator is gonna, that the iterator in the innermost loop is going to return. And so I think it's a kind of clever little protocol. And I prototyped a library based for each equivalent for it.
也就是它在最外层循环中所处的迭代的索引，从这里你可以某种程度上逐步构建出最终的索引，也就是你的迭代器将要返回的索引，也就是最内层循环中的迭代器将要返回的索引。所以我认为这是一个挺聪明的协议。我为它原型化了一个基于for each等效的库。
And I imagine that we could have a sort of a space-based for loop, just like how we have a range-based for loop that understands this protocol. And I also think that it's a model that'll be composable too, because we could make it pipeable, we can make spaces pipeable just like ranges.
而且我想象我们可以有一种基于空间的for循环，就像我们有理解这个协议的基于范围的for循环一样。我也认为这是一个可组合的模型，因为我们可以把它做成可管道化的（pipeable），我们可以让空间像范围一样支持管道操作。
And the default would be that you could pipe in range adapters and those would operate on the innermost iterator but you can also imagine having some new adapter like call it on extents that would say hey I want to apply this particular transformation to just one of the particular extents. And through that way you can get to a nice compositional model. And I think that this model will let us get good code gen, but also have all the properties that we're looking for, like composability and an ability to write generic multidimensional code. And that's going to be rank agnostic and location agnostic and layout agnostic, et cetera.
默认情况下，你可以通过管道传入范围适配器，这些适配器将在最内层的迭代器上运行，但你也可以想象拥有某种新的适配器，比如叫on extents，它会说，嘿，我想把这个特定的变换应用到其中某一个特定的范围上。通过这种方式，你可以得到一个很好的组合模型。我认为这个模型能让我们获得良好的代码生成，同时具备我们所寻找的所有属性，比如可组合性以及编写通用多维代码的能力。而且它将是与秩无关（rank agnostic）、位置无关（location agnostic）以及布局无关（layout agnostic）的，等等。
Yeah, we should dedicate a whole episode or maybe two in the future to not necessarily diving into details, but talking about MD-SPAN because I feel like the direction that this podcast is going and my work's going and your work's going is like MD-SPAN is going to start to come up a lot more, but without diving into a complete explanation or high level view, uh, extent, um, cause that's something for a while. I didn't, I didn't get what that was. Would you like to explain to the listener what, what, what the extents object is or what an extent is both the latter though first. Well, an extent is just like a um you know it's an axis of a dimension you know um uh so like the you know the the c or if you have like a 2d matrix
是的，我们应该在未来专门用一期或两期节目，不一定非要深入细节，而是来讨论MD-SPAN，因为我觉得这个播客的发展方向、我的工作以及你的工作，都表明MD-SPAN将会越来越多地被提及，但在不深入探讨完整解释或高层视图的情况下，extent，呃，因为那是我有一段时间没搞懂的东西。你想向听众解释一下extent对象是什么，或者说extent是什么吗？虽然我们要先从后者说起。好吧，extent就像是一个，呃，你知道的，它是维度的轴，你知道的，呃，所以就像，你知道的，C++或者如果你有一个二维矩阵
you know it has two extents and each one of those has like a length to them right so so for our listeners and this is why i guess it wasn't necessarily confusing, but the first time I heard extent, it was just not in my lexicon. Yeah, I don't know why we picked that word. I did not know why they called it that. Yeah, we could have called it dimension. I think you would typically think of it as dimension, but there's a reason that we didn't do that. Colloquially, it's referred to as dimension, but in the array world and array languages, they refer to them as axes. And that's actually, we kind of talked about that one or two episodes ago um i think it was last episode which
你知道它有两个extent，每个extent都有一个长度，对吧？所以对我们的听众来说——我想这也是为什么它一开始不一定让人困惑，但我第一次听到extent这个词时，它确实不在我的词汇表中。是的，我不知道我们为什么挑了那个词。我也不知道他们为什么要那样称呼它。是的，我们本可以叫它维度（dimension）。我想你通常会认为它是维度，但我们没有这样做是有原因的。在俗语中，它被称为维度，但在数组世界和数组语言中，它们被称为轴（axes）。事实上，我们在一两集之前讨论过这个，呃，我想那是上一集，
actually hasn't been released yet well that it'll be coming out this friday but listeners already listened to it potentially a week ago and yeah so to rephrase it in like array language speak when you have a matrix aka a rank two array aka a two-dimensional array you have two dimensions or two axes the first and the second or zero and one and so in bryce's talk uh you'll see a lot of code that is you know has on extent and then zero one or two and it's very thought provocative because this is actually, and maybe we're going to have to bring Marshall on because I mentioned in, in,
其实那一集还没发布，不过它会在这个星期五上线，但听众可能已经在大概一周前听过了。是的，所以用数组语言的话来重新表述，当你有一个矩阵，也就是秩为2的数组，也就是二维数组时，你有两个维度或两个轴，也就是第一轴和第二轴，或者0和1。所以在布莱斯的演讲中，你会看到很多代码，比如有on extent然后是0、1或2，这非常耐人寻味，因为这实际上——也许我们需要把马歇尔（Marshall）请来，因为我在最新一期的ArrayCast节目中提到了，我谈到了不断演化的康纳和布莱斯电影宇宙（cinematic podcast universe），因为现在我们将有一位来自ArrayCast的嘉宾来到ADSP。我的第三个播客也要推出了，但我甚至还没录制第一集。所以事情会变得复杂，各位。我们谈论的不是《权力的游戏》那种复杂，但
in the most recent array cast episode, I talked about the evolving Connor and Bryce cinematic podcast, cinematic universe, because now we're going to have a panelist from array cast coming on ADSP. We've got my third podcast coming out, which I still haven't recorded my first episode for. So it's going to get complicated, folks. We're not talking Game of Thrones complicated, but
它确实会变得复杂，而且会有人跨界到不同的播客。我们会请马歇尔来的。但在最新的一期节目中，我们在ArrayCast上讨论了你如何通过这种前导轴理论（leading axis theory）来获得一定程度的访问权限，
it is going to get complicated and there's going to be people crossing, you know, podcasts. We'll bring Marshall on. But the most recent episode we talked about on ArrayCast was how you only get a certain amount of access to drilling down using this leading axis theory
这样你就可以对某个特定的秩进行操作，但你可能必须重塑你的数据，以便专门对某个特定的数据块进行操作，然后你需要一种叫做双adic转置（dyadic transpose）的东西——比如矩阵的转置、二维矩阵相当直接，但如果你有一个三维或N维数组，它不仅仅是一个矩阵，转置会是什么样的呢？有趣的是，在不同的数组语言中它是不同的，在APL和J中，我相信它们只是颠倒了形状。如果你有一个立方体，维度是2、3、4，你只需颠倒它，它就变成4、3、2。在BQN中，它们做的是一次旋转（one rotate）。它们把第一个维度移到最后。但更具体地说，你可以做任何
so you can operate on a certain rank but you might have to reshape your data in order to specifically work on a specific specific chunk and you then need something called a dyadic transpose so like a transpose of a matrix 2d matrix pretty straightforward but what if you have a uh three or n dimensional array that is more than just a matrix what does a transpose look like there interestingly it's like different across the array languages in apl and j i believe they just reverse the shape. So if you have a cube and the dimensions are 2, 3, 4, you just reverse it and it becomes 4, 3, 2. In BQN, they do a one rotate. So they take the first dimension and move it to the back. But more specifically, you can do like any
任意的形状重塑，这就是双adic转置（dyadic transpose）——它是一个接受两个参数的转置，比如你的矩阵和这个新的基本类似于等级（grade）的东西，也就是对轴的重新排序，用MD-SPAN的话说就是extent。现在你在谈论这个新的潜在模型，它们完全不同，而且我对你的理解还不够深入，不过肯定的是，你能用双adic做的一切事情，我觉得它们可能同构，但不可否认的是，数组界的人把双adic转置称为最复杂的事情之一。我的问题是，所有这些复杂性——显然存在一组特定的问题，
arbitrary reshape, which is what a dyadic transpose is it's a transpose that takes two arguments like your matrix and then this new basically like grade if you will so it's the reordering of the axes aka extents and md span speak and now you're talking about this like new potential model and they're completely different and i don't understand yours well enough but definitely you could do everything you can do with dyadic i think like they're completely different. And I don't understand yours well enough, but definitely you could do everything you can do with dyadic. I think like they're probably isomorphic, but admittedly array people, they talk about dyadic transpose as being like one of the most complicated things. And my question is like all of this complexity, obviously there's a certain set of problems
使得你必须能够做这些事情。但这主要是由行业问题驱动的吗，比如在HPC中你有一堆需要这个的东西——比如extent extent点点形状形状，还是说是由硬件驱动的，你知道的，必须用分块（tiling）之类的高效算法来实现？多维，呃，多维空间在硬件中是逻辑上的，而不是物理上的。在GPU上，有一点这方面的概念，但即使那样实际上也是物理上的，
that necessitates you being able to do this stuff. But is this like, is this mostly driven by industry problems like an hpc you've got a bunch of stuff that requires this like whoo extent extent dot dot shape shape or is it like the hardware that you know and having to do like efficient algorithm implementation with tiling and stuff multi-dimensional um uh multi-dimensional spaces are logical, not physical in hardware. On GPUs, there's a little bit of a notion of that, but even that is actually physical,
是逻辑上的，而不是物理上的。当我说的物理时，我的意思是就进程如何寻址内存而言的物理。我确实承认有些类型的内存实际上是多维的。但是不，通常我们认为内存是一个线性的存储区，通常是这样的。所以我们在其之上添加的任何多维性都是一个逻辑层。我想，我是说，我不知道我这个问题是不是问对了，但所有这些——为了给用户提供一种完全通用的方式来深入到任何extent或某些多维事物的轴而必须引入的复杂性——我不知道，我至今还没遇到过这样的问题，但
is logical, not physical. And when I say physical, I mean physical in terms of how processes address memory. I do recognize that there are some types of memory that are actually multidimensional. But no, normally we think of memory as a linear store, typically. And so whatever multidimensionality we add on top of it is a logical layer. I guess, I mean, I'm not sure if that was, I asked my question correctly, but like all of this, like the complexity that you have to introduce in order to give the user a completely generic way to drill down to like any extant or axis of some multi-dimensional thing is that like i don't know i've yet to come across problems but
我不怎么在HPC领域工作，而且我通常是编写库而不是使用库，我只是不知道，你知道的，复杂性来自于应用吗？是的，确实如此。我是说，接口上的复杂性——关于你想做什么，而我们如何实现它的复杂性——当然来自于硬件，你知道的，正如我们今天在我的主题演讲中所讨论的那样，有许多种自然的方法来在C++中实现多维迭代器，但它们只会导致糟糕的代码生成。但是，你知道的，应用层面的问题是，是的，它们很自然地具有这种
like i don't operate in the hpc space and i usually am writing libraries not using them i just don't know like uh you know the complexity comes from the applications yes it does i mean the the complexity of the like on the interface on like what you want to do the complexity and like how we implement it certainly comes from the hardware you know like as we discussed in my keynote today there's you know there are a number of sort of natural approaches to how you do multi-dimensional iterators in c++ which just lead to terrible code gen. But, you know, the application problem is like, yeah, they're naturally, they have this
结构，它们有多个维度。我不否认多个维度是存在的。我是说，想要做诸如分块（tiling）之类的事情有点像是由性能驱动的。而我的想法是，很多时候，至少——不一定非要是GPU，但我们在英伟达工作，我的想法是，像很多，你知道的，
structure where they have multiple dimensions. I don't disagree that the multiple dimensions exist. I mean, wanting to do things like tiling is sort of like performance driven. And that's what my thought is, is that a lot of the way that, at least, it doesn't necessarily have to be GPUs, but that's we work at NVIDIA i and that's what my thought is is that like a lot of the you know the way that
至少（不一定非要是GPU，但我们在英伟达工作，而且GPU很多时候）如果你能把你的矩阵乘法转化某种分块矩阵乘法，你知道的，GPU就会说“姆姆，谢谢你的更多食物”呃，但这并不是由某种应用层面的问题驱动的。这是硬件工作的方式，因此如果我们有一种通用的方法来编写这个算法的实现，使其能够超级简单地进行分块，那就太好了。
at least you know it doesn't necessarily have to be gpus but that's we work at nvidia and that gpus a lot of the times if you can translate your you know matrix multiply and some some sort of tiled matrix multiply you know the gpu goes nom nom thank you for the more food um uh but that's like that's not driven by that's not driven by some application-level problem. This is the way the hardware works, and therefore it'd be nice if we had a generic way to write the implementation of this algorithm such that it could be tiled super simply.
是的，是的。我是说，如果你看看你编写矩阵乘法的朴素方式与编写高效矩阵乘法的区别，它们非常不同，而且它们之所以非常不同，是因为，你知道的，为了获得性能而编写代码的方式将与朴素的方式极其不同，因为你必须考虑
Yeah, yeah. I mean, if you look at the naive way that you write a matrix multiply versus how you write an efficient matrix multiply, they're very different, and they're very different because, you know, the way that you write to get performance is just going to be very, very different than the naive way because you have to think about
诸如局部性（locality）和内存访问模式（memory access patterns）之类的事情。哦，说到这里，这完全是随机的，听众可能听不懂，但你那三张图表——行主序、列主序，然后第三个是什么？莫顿序（Morton order）。莫顿序。你是从别处弄来的还是自己做的？不，我做的。你做的？我做的。在PowerPoint里做的，我是在PowerPoint里做的。在PowerPoint里，哇，真的，听众朋友们，你们
things like locality and memory access patterns. Oh, speaking of which, this is totally random and the listener won't get it, but those three diagrams that you had, row major, column major, and then what was the third one was? Morton order. Morton order. Did you pull those off of or did you make those? No, I made those. You made those? I made those. In PowerPoint i made those in powerpoint i'm in powerpoint wow very listener yeah you
真该去看看这个主题演讲——就为了那些……那是你第一次把这个塞进去吗？还是你之前就有了？所以你是专门为这个演示文稿制作的？你知道的，我是怎么做这种事情的……你见过我的小红框吗？我没有……所以，我用PowerPoint的秘诀之一是——箭头和PowerPoint中的形状是相连的，但它们并不总是连接到形状中有用的地方，
should just go watch this keynote uh just for those is that the first time you've you've snuck that into or did you have that before so you made it specifically for this deck you know you know how i do do things like that uh you've seen my little red boxes i don't so so so what one of my secrets to powerpoint is like so arrows and powerpoints connect to shapes um but they don't always connect to shapes in like useful places um and so like sometimes like when you're wanting wanting things to be nice and aligned instead of just like having arrows and lines that you try to manually align, it can be really useful to make little boxes and put them in the right places.
所以有时当你希望事情排列得整整齐齐，而不是仅仅依赖手动对齐的箭头和线条时，制作小方框并把它们放在正确的位置会非常有用。然后你可以把线条连接到这些方框上，接着你可以把这些方框设为100%透明，100%透明的好处在于，这意味着你可以把它们放在最上层，这样当需要移动它们时你可以点击并找到它们，但没有人能看到它们。我总是把这些小方框做成红色的，这样当我把透明度调回来时，很容易就能看到它们。所以在那个二维矩阵上——我画了顺序线条的那个，
Then you can connect lines to those, and then you can make those boxes 100% transparency, which is not 100% transparency is nice because it means that you can put them on the top layer so you can click them and get to them if you need to move them around but nobody can see them. And I always make these little boxes red so that when I turn the transparency back down again it's easy to see them. So on that little 2D matrix that I had where I put the lines of the orders
在每一个矩阵的正中心都有一个小红框，我就是用它来连接线条的。因为，是的，亲爱的听众朋友们，PowerPoint是我的日常工作，这意味着我已经掌握了一些PowerPoint技能。我不知道我们以前在播客里聊过这个没有。没有，这是我第一次听说。没有，那些快捷工具。我有一个PowerPoint插件，我不记得它的确切名字了，但我们会在show
in the center of each one of those matrices is a little red box that I used to connect up the lines. Because, yes, dear listener, PowerPoint is my day job, which means I have acquired some PowerPoint skills. I don't know if we've talked about it on this podcast before. No, this is the first time I've heard it. No, the shortcut tools. I had this PowerPoint plug-in that I don't remember the exact name of it, but we'll put a link to it in the show
notes里放一个链接。这个插件太棒了，因为它提供了一些非常有用的PowerPoint动作，比如“复制对象的位置”。所以你不是复制整个东西，而是只复制它的位置，然后你可以粘贴这个位置，把另一个对象放在相同的位置，这在你想跨行对齐东西时非常有用。它还为所有对齐操作提供了快捷键，因为通常你必须进入排列菜单然后点击其中一个。我从不需要那样做。我有我的快捷键。
notes. But this plugin is amazing because it gives you a couple of very useful PowerPoint actions, like copy position of a thing. So instead of copying the whole thing, you just copy its position and then you can paste the position to put some other object the same position, which is really useful when you're trying to align things across lines. It also has key bindings for all of the alignment things because usually you have to go into a range and then click on one of those things. I never have to do that. I just got my key bindings.
我是一个PowerPoint巫师。康纳是一个Excel巫师。康纳的生活靠电子表格运行，正如他刚才在本期节目早些时候所提到的。我的生活靠PowerPoint运行。我觉得我还没达到你的水平，但如果你是三重黑带，我大概是单黑带。你今天确实教了我关于变形（morph）的功能。是的。我是说，嗯，刚才你说的那些有键盘快捷键的功能。
I am a PowerPoint wizard. Connor's an Excel wizard. Connor's life runs on spreadsheets, as he just mentioned earlier in this episode. My life runs on PowerPoint. I don't think I'm your level, but if you're like a triple black belt, I'm probably like a single black belt. You did teach me today about the morph thing. Yeah. I mean, well, so what you just said you have keyboard shortcuts for.
我是说，这跑题了。其实，我们要把这个跑题再拉偏一点。我找到了你提到的那个Reddit帖子，当时你提到有人说你太漫不经心（nonchalant）了。有一个Reddit帖子的标题是“CPP cast结束了。我们现在听什么？”基本上50%的人都在推荐那些较新的C++节目，你知道的，因为有些节目会讨论其他事情，比如像我们这样的。所以，你知道，ADSP、TLB hit、Two's Compliment、NDR。这些大概是四个。然后还有一堆C++之外的其他节目。但随后有一条评论说，是的，你知道，我真的很喜欢ADSP。
I mean, this derailed. Actually, we're going to derail this derailment. I found that Reddit thread that you said when you mentioned that some people were saying you're too nonchalant. And so there was a Reddit thread that was entitled CPP cast is over. What what do we listen to now? And it was basically a 50% were recommending sort of the the newer C++, you know, plus because some of them talk about other things like ours. So, you know, ADSP, TLB hit, Two's Compliment, NDR. So those are the sort of the four. And then there was a bunch of other ones outside of C++. But then there was one comment that said like, yeah, you know, I really like ADSP.
但接着有一堆回复，里面说，是的，布莱斯太漫不经心了。但它还说这个播客……是的，我根本不在乎。看，这就是我的漫不经心。但它还说这个播客……是的，我根本不在乎。看，这就叫漫不经心。不过另一条评论，我觉得最搞笑的是，它是批评我们的播客缺乏结构。
But then there was like a bunch of responses, which in it said, yes, Bryce is too nonchalant. But it also said that the podcast. Yeah, I don't really care. See, it's just me being nonchalant. But it also said that the podcast... Yeah, I don't really care. See, that's just me being nonchalant. The other comment, though, that I just find hilarious is that it was the criticism that our podcast lacks structure. please go back to the beginning and listen when this podcast was inspired by Magic Readalong a 20 to 25 minute telephone conversation if you will between Dr. Boolean
请回到开头去听听，当这个播客受到《Magic Readalong》的启发时，那是一场20分到25分钟的电话交谈，如果你愿意的话，在布尔博士（Dr. Boolean）
and I can't even remember the other words because they would never even introduce ours has an intro little jingle theirs literally like it would just start hey man how's it going wouldn't say their names for like up to episode 40 I didn't even know Dr. Boolean because they never plugged their Twitter handles they never plugged for ratings which is why i basically said only once every 50 episodes are we going to say go to your blah blah blah
和我之间——我甚至记不清其他人的名字了，因为他们甚至从不介绍自己。我们的播客有片头小曲，他们的播客简直就是直接开始：嘿，老兄，最近怎么样？连续40集都不说自己的名字，我甚至不知道布尔博士是谁，因为他们从不推广自己的推特账号，从不为了评分而宣传，这就是为什么我基本上说过，每50集我们才会说一次“请前往你们的巴拉巴拉”，
we're not going to do it now that doesn't count but the point is is like we modeled this pod i modeled this podcast off of magic read-along which doesn't even um record or release anymore but it was specifically the lack of structure that I liked. And so I just thought it was funny that they're like, yeah, you know, this could do with a little more structure. I'm not denying that our podcast probably could do. It's by design. But it's by design that it's not there.
我们现在不会这么做，那个不算数。但重点是，我们模仿了这个播客——我模仿这个播客是照着《Magic Readalong》来的，那个播客现在甚至不录制或发布了，但我喜欢它的一点恰恰就是缺乏结构。所以我觉得很好笑的是，他们说，是的，你知道，这可以再多一点结构。我并不否认我们的播客可能确实需要……这是有意为之的。但它没有结构是设计使然。
So back to the PowerPoint, Morph Transition. Oh, no. So before Morph, I was going to say the things that you have key bindings for, I have the shortcuts. So you can add little icons. So it's still a single click. But, yeah, I have all those. Like basically the distribute evenly and horizontally, the align left, right, center, middle. Those are like bread and butter.
所以回到PowerPoint，变形转场（Morph Transition）。哦，不。所以在Morph出现之前，我要说的是你有快捷键的那些功能。你可以添加小图标。所以仍然只需点击一下。但是，是的，我都有这些。基本上就是水平和垂直平均分布，左对齐、右对齐、居中、垂直居中。这些简直是基本功。
You have to have it. Yep. And the thing today, and this is probably the number one question I've been asked post-talks. It has nothing to do with my technical content. It's always like great transitions. How do you do the thing where you get code, one piece of code to transform into another? And in Microsoft PowerPoint 2019
你必须得有。是的。而今天的事情——这可能是我在演讲后被问到最多的问题。它与我的技术内容毫无关系。总是有人问：转场效果太棒了。你是怎么做到让一段代码转换成另一段代码的？在微软的PowerPoint 2019
and some later editions of 2017, but usually you just want to get 2019, they added a transition called Morph. Keynote, Apple's keynote, the PowerPoint clone, has had something like this called Magic Move, I believe, for years. Some people are going to take issue with you categorizing it as the PowerPoint clone. I mean, admittedly, didn't their software suite come out like years after Microsoft? I don't know. I just said, my point is just we're going to get letters.
以及2017年的一些后续版本中（但通常你只需要2019年），他们添加了一个叫做Morph（变形）的转场效果。苹果的Keynote——PowerPoint的克隆版，多年前就有一种叫做“魔幻移动”（Magic Move）的类似功能。有些人会对你把它归类为PowerPoint的克隆版产生异议。我是说，诚实地说，他们的软件套件不是比微软晚出来好几年吗？我不知道。我只是说，重点是我们会收到抗议信的。
All I know is Keynote is they got that one animation where the text falls down and then creates a sort of little dust cloud. And I'm like, oh, that's Keynote. Because that's what they always used to do. Or Steve Jobs, you know, they'd have some number and then it'd be 10 billion devices sold or whatever. Anyways, Morph was added. But the key thing is that some
我只知道Keynote有那种文字落下然后创造出某种小尘埃云的动画。然后我就想，哦，那是Keynote。因为他们以前总是那样做。或者史蒂夫·乔布斯，你知道的，他们会展示某个数字，然后是售出100亿台设备之类的。无论如何，Morph被加入了进来。但关键是，有些人
people will try morph and every single animation and transition or most of them have like uh effect properties or transition properties and so you need to go and click on that and there's three different ones object words and characters and for code transitions you always want to choose either words or characters and the default is objects so it'll actually pick out the words that are you know consistent between two slide examples and i was telling bryce how does it do that that's really it must be a very very like and that's the thing is some people have criticized especially when it's apl because like it looks really nice when you have like c++ or python code and it transitions because no one's
会尝试使用Morph，而几乎每个动画和转场（或大多数转场）都有一些效果属性或转场属性，所以你需要去点击它，那里有三个不同的选项：对象（objects）、词（words）和字符（characters）。对于代码转场，你总是应该选择“词”或“字符”，而默认选项是“对象”。所以它实际上会挑出两个幻灯片示例中一致的词，我当时还在告诉布莱斯它是怎么做到的，这真的很……那一定是一个非常非常……而且问题就在于，有些人批评过这一点，特别是当涉及到APL时，因为当你使用C++或Python代码并且它进行转场时，看起来真的很不错，因为没有人
going to be able to track you know exactly what went where it just looks nice but with apl sometimes you only have like four characters on the screen and then you transition but what it does is it it finds the closest word or character so like sometimes especially if you're dealing with a an array of ones and zeros and you're trying to like add 10 to it or something a one that really was being turned into a two will actually slide across and become the first one in the 10 and that that's not actually what you want. And you actually could have seen that in, I did a first 10 odd numbers when I went from one to 10, then two to 20, and then one to 19, the ones and stuff were sort of moving around. So it doesn't work perfectly, but it's basically like some kind of shortest distance algorithm to some object identifier. But do you think they pre-bake that? I don't think that they can. What do you mean
能够追踪到到底是什么去了哪里，它看起来只是很酷。但对于APL，有时屏幕上只有四个字符，然后你进行转场，但它所做的是——它寻找最近的词或字符，所以有时，特别是如果你处理的是由1和0组成的数组，并且你试图给它加上10之类的值，原本要变成2的那个1实际上会滑过去，变成10里面的第一个1，而这其实并不是你想要的。你实际上可以在我做“前10个奇数”的时候看到这一点，当我从1到10，然后从2到20，再从1到19时，数字1之类的东西在四处移动。所以它并不是完美工作的，但它基本上类似于某种针对某个对象标识符的最短距离算法。但你觉得它们是预先渲染（pre-bake）好的吗？我不认为它们能……你这话是什么意思？
pre-bake? Like, do you think that they pre-bake that transition? Like they pre-bake that? I don't think that they can. What do you mean pre-bake? Like, do you think that they pre-bake that transition? Like, they pre-bake the compute of, like, what they're going to map to what, and that gets saved in the PowerPoint? Or do you think that it's done dynamically? I'm trying to even... Like, it has to be done, like, on the fly. Yeah, yeah. I mean, like, they could do it either way,
预先渲染？比如，你觉得它们是预先渲染了那个转场吗？就像它们预先渲染好那个？我不认为它们能。你这话是什么意思，预先渲染？比如，你觉得它们是预先渲染了那个转场？就像它们预先渲染了计算过程，关于什么将映射到什么，然后这个被保存在PowerPoint中？还是你觉得它是动态完成的？我在试图理解……这必须是，像是在运行时实时完成的。对，对。我是说，它们可以以任何一种方式实现，
but why would why would you go to the effort of like saving it because you just have to update it every single time you change something on the slide it wouldn't make any sense i wonder if we can we could probably come up with some like some stress tests that would really slow powerpoint down for this you put a lot of words on the screen oh yeah yeah maybe i mean uh maybe. I mean, well, so we'll link in the show notes. And I think I've mentioned this before. What algorithm do you use to do that? I'm sure it has a name of just like shortest object, shortest distance.
但为什么你要费力去保存它呢？因为每次你在幻灯片上修改任何东西时，你都得更新它，这根本说不通。我在想，我们或许可以想出一些压力测试，能够真正把PowerPoint卡死。你在屏幕上放了海量的文字。哦，对，对，也许吧，也许。我是说，嗯，我们会在show notes里附上链接。我想我以前提到过这个。你用的是什么算法来做这个？我确信它有一个名字，比如“最短对象”、“最短距离”。
But like there's no way that's like linear. It's got to be worse than linear. Oh, no, yeah, it is. If you have a complicated like it'll start to, especially if you have like a huge wall of text. Yeah. Characters are not too bad. But like as soon as you're doing words, words I think is actually a little bit trickier.
但这绝对不可能是线性的。它的复杂度肯定比线性要糟。哦，不，是的，确实如此。如果你有一个复杂的……它就会开始变慢，特别是当你有一整面墙的文字时。是的。字符还不算太糟。但一旦你处理词，词其实会更棘手一点。
No, words has to be worse. A wall of text is just going to be bad. But I'll link in the show notes, the way I learned this was this crazy PowerPoint hacks. And basically what this guy was showing, the presenter, is that obviously if you've got a rectangle that turns you know from a purple rectangle to a blue square it can figure that out and it'll actually transition the colors and the shape but like if you're trying to make a star object turn into a circle well like those are actually two different objects but what you can do is group groups of
不，词的算法肯定更糟。满屏的文字效果肯定会很糟糕。但我会在show notes里附上链接，我学到这个的方法是通过一些疯狂的PowerPoint黑客技巧。这个人——也就是演讲者——展示的基本意思是，很明显，如果你有一个矩形，你知道的，它从一个紫色矩形变成一个蓝色正方形，它能搞清楚这一点，并且它实际上会过渡颜色和形状，但如果你试图把一个星星对象变成一个圆形，嗯，那些实际上是两个不同的对象，但你可以做的是把成组的
objects together and then you can make one of them like the primary there's some way to like you know you put a square but make it invisible and then take a circle and a star and then it'll it'll see that we have two bundles and they both include a square and then they will morph like the star into the circle and that like and he starts and he shows and so if you really take this crazy and then he builds this whole animation that looks like it was something designed in, you know, whatever, 2005 Flash. And, yeah, PowerPoint, like I said, I might not be a triple black belt. We're going to have to look up what algorithm you'd use for this, and we're going to have to talk about it. I would love, I mean, I said this back when we did the Excel episode, to bring some of the Microsoft. If we happen to have any Microsoft devs that work on PowerPoint or Excel or anything
把对象组合在一起，然后你可以把其中一个设为主对象，比如你可以放一个正方形但让它不可见，然后拿一个圆圈和一个星星，它就会发现我们有两个包，它们都包含一个正方形，然后它们会变形，比如把星星变成圆圈，诸如此类，他开始展示，如果你真的把这个发挥到极致，然后他构建了整个动画，看起来就像是用，你知道的，不管怎样，2005年的Flash设计出来的东西。而且，对，PowerPoint，就像我说的，我可能不是黑带三段。我们要查一下你会用什么算法来实现这个，我们要讨论一下。我很想，我是说，早在我们做Excel那一期的时候我就说过，想把一些微软的员工请来。如果我们刚好有任何微软的开发人员从事PowerPoint、Excel或任何
in the office suite. I actually added a couple people on LinkedIn when I was at CppCon 2019 because I ran into them and they were like, oh yeah, we work on Excel. And then I just lost it. I was like, I love Excel so much. I used to have three versions. Microsoft, Excel people, call us. Yeah. We want to talk to you.
Office套件的工作。我在2019年CppCon大会上其实加了几个人的LinkedIn，因为我遇到了他们，他们说，哦，对，我们做Excel。然后我就有点失控了。我当时想，我太喜欢Excel了。我以前有三个版本。微软的Excel朋友们，联系我们吧。对。我们想和你们聊聊。
Yeah. So this became an episode mostly about PowerPoint. I don't think that this episode was mostly about anything. Yeah. Yeah. Should we wrap it up? We should probably wrap it up and go back to the conference. Anything else we want to say to the listener?
对。所以这一期基本上变成了关于PowerPoint的一期。我不觉得这一期主要是关于什么的。对。对。我们要收尾了吗？我们大概应该收尾，然后回会议现场去了。还有什么想对听众说的吗？
When's the next time we're going to be in the same spot? Oh, yeah. In a month. CPP North. CPP North. Yeah. Stay tuned. Who are we bringing on?
我们下次聚在一起是什么时候？哦，对。一个月后。CPP North。CPP North。对。敬请期待。我们要请谁来？
So we've got Tony's going to be there. We have to record a bunch of episodes between now and July because I'm going to be in London and then Tokyo. Yeah, we can do it. So like, Tony's going to be at CPP North. So is Titus. I think Chandler's going to be there as well. And Sean, parents, also going to be there.
所以Tony会去。从现在到7月我们得录制好几期节目，因为我要去伦敦，然后去东京。对，我们能做到。所以，Tony会去CPP North。Titus也会去。我想Chandler也会去。还有Sean Parents也去。
Anyways, we've got a bunch of people that have been on our list of people to talk to. You said you want to bring Titus on. Yeah. I said I wanted to bring Sean and Tony. Maybe we could have a big, do you think Chandler and Titus would come on at the same time? Yeah, sure. Why not? Anyways.
不管怎样，我们有一堆一直在交流名单上的人。你说过你想把Titus请来。对。我说我想把Sean和Tony请来。也许我们可以搞个大的，你觉得Chandler和Titus会同时上节目吗？对，当然。为什么不呢？总之。
Two for the price of one. I think Sean and Tony are the – actually, that was half the people I just listed. Yeah. Sean and Tony together are good. Yeah. Anyways. And maybe we'll do another live. We definitely got to do a couple live ones at Live's Ones.
买一送一。我觉得Sean和Tony是——其实那正是我刚才列出的人的一半。对。Sean和Tony在一起挺好的。对。总之。也许我们还会做一次现场录制。我们绝对得在现场录制几期。
Although I feel like what people expect from the live episode is not us sitting in an empty conference room, but like the atmosphere. Like we should go find some people. Well, so that's the problem is like we, this is an academic crowd. I know a lot of these people from having watched the virtual ones, but like who do we, we know Doug Greger here. Yeah, but we should wrap it up because this room is freezing and I need to be somewhere warm yeah it's surprisingly cold in San Diego yeah I'm wearing a like
虽然我觉得大家对现场节目的期望不是我们坐在空荡荡的会议室里，而是那种氛围。比如我们应该去找些人。嗯，问题就在于，我们，这是一群学术界的人。我通过看虚拟会议认识这里的很多人，但我们该找谁，我们在这里认识Doug Greger。对，但我们该收尾了，因为这个房间冷得要命，我得去个暖和的地方，对啊，圣迭戈出奇地冷，对啊，我穿着一件像
I said a pink hoodie yeah which I will try to change out before we go to dinner tonight yeah we're not going to someplace cheap for dinner all right listener signing out from San Diego see ya soon
我说的粉色连帽衫，对，我今晚去吃晚饭前会尽量换掉它，对，我们晚饭不会去便宜的地方吃的，好了，听众朋友们，从圣迭戈向大家告别，回头见
except not because we don't see our listeners we might see some of them conference season is starting that's true
不过其实不是，因为我们看不到我们的听众，我们可能会在会议上见到其中一些人，会议季开始了，确实如此
that's true like I said like I just said yeah Sean and Tony definitely listen yeah so we'll be seeing both of them
确实如此，就像我说的，就像我刚才说的，对，Sean和Tony绝对会听，对，所以我们会见到他们两个
anyways till next time till next time later thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
总之，下次见，下次见，回头见，感谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。